and another thing that i want to i i'd
like to point out to people that
you've got to look at the world now
especially if you're a young male or
even a young female in terms of being
anti-fragile
and uh you know the world is a very
tumultuous place i can go through and
talk about chart you know at
macroeconomic charts but even from a
standpoint of personal freedom and
liberty you know if i would have told
you in 2019 that the global governments
were going to lock you in a cage for a
year you'd have said that you're
absolutely out of your mind okay we saw
that and they're taking away more of our
personal freedoms and liberties and
everyone asks me well george what's the
perfect country to go to if you want to
maximize your personal freedom and
liberty
and i say there is none because every
single country is run by a socialist
you you name me the country right now in
the world that's not run by a
megalomaniac or some or a socialist
slash marxist with this global agenda
there isn't any right so i think you
need to be very nimble from a standpoint
of your lifestyle and i i would i'm
probably not a minimalist because when i
i rent a place you know for three or
four months it's it's not
it's pretty you're more of a little most
than i
because here's something i've realized
about myself because dude i'm like i'm
looking at like a
little older version of myself i pray to
get george's position you know x amount
of years down the road but i view myself
as a minimalist i don't have a car
yeah okay i rent my apartment i don't
buy like all my you guys groceries and
cook for yourself oh all instagram just
go in yeah instacart i mean i don't
like everything like people are like i i
don't have hobbies i don't go
skateboarding i don't do rock climbing i
don't have a card collection i don't
play the guitar i like to do a few
things i like to make money because that
gives me economic freedom to go wherever
i want to go
more than anything i like to kick it
with my boys and laugh have a good time
and learn and quite frankly i like to
hang out with beautiful women and have a
good time and i have a bar in south
beach and i invite them there that's
what i like to do and i don't have to
own anything to do that you're right
it's kind of like what you're saying is
like you don't have a guitar collection
you don't have any of this that kind of
stuff explain why you're kind of a
minimalist but not full-on minimalism
well again it gives you that freedom i i
think people need to remember that we're
not vegetables
so what my point is
to say that well i'm going to go to
miami or i'm going to go to xyz country
and set up you know i'm going to plant
roots there and i'm going to be there
for the next 10 years or 20 years you're
living like a tree uh why would anyone
want to do that what i do is i say i
feel like spending the next uh three
months or six months in medellin
that's what i'm going to do
where do i want to go after that i don't
know i'm leaving my options open because
i'm not a vegetable
and also in today's environment i think
that's very important from that
standpoint of being anti-fragile i think
in the past you could select a country
and say okay five years ten years from
now the country is probably going to
look like this
uh but i don't not even with the united
states i mean look at what happened in
australia they said these quarantine
camps look at what happened that was one
of those canada places absolutely canada
which you would have said
you know in 2019 was a pretty quote
unquote free country so going back to
the the minimalist thing the way i
prefer to live
is uh let's use medellin as an example i
spend maybe four or five months a year
there but i'm not
locked down to it you know if i don't
want to spend time in medellin i won't
do it but i've got a staff of people so
i've got a driver i've got a personal
chef i've got a gal that does all the
the laundry i mean i don't lift a finger
to do anything i've got my assistant
down there so i i'm
liv literally living like a billionaire
down there
of course but that said i could pack
everything that i do own into a couple
duffel bags and go to uh you know go to
podcast
go to st bart's for three or four months
can i ask you a very expensive place
i've been yeah one of the very expensive
yes
i got i broke up with my ex because
we're like we're not going back there
um but let me push back if you will
because there's going to be people
saying well george hell yeah i want to
do that but i got a wife and kids bro
yeah right so what would you say to
those people so for those people i would
set up a plan b to make sure that you
can maximize the amount of freedom in
your life playing the hand that you're
dealt or that you've got right now so uh
sure you might not be able to pick up
and go to
st bart's in 2020 like i did just
because it's the only place that didn't
have lockdowns
but what you can do is you can have an
rv in your driveway so if we do get
riots and social unrest which i think
will get more of in the future not less
of
then you've got you can pack your family
up there you can go to
pinetop if you're in
arizona as an example and just relax you
got some way to get out of the line of
fire
maybe literally and so that gives you a
little bit more of that freedom are you
going to be able to live uh you know
like a doug casey or george cam maybe
not
but it's far better than what your
friends are doing to where if the riots
come to your neighborhood you're just
stuck there you're going to lock the
door and maybe go down to the basement
and just keep your fingers crossed you
know that that's uh just you're an
ostrich bearing your head in the sand
and i don't think that's a prudent way
to live going into what i think is a
fourth turning that'll last until
probably 20 30 or so and you talk about
um
you know essentially what you're saying
is
figure out a way to get out of the rat
race figure out a way to unplug yourself
from the matrix they'll use a red pill
example so you can be flexible
flexibility is the new american dream or
the world dream so you could just kind
of go where you want to you know we can
get on a flight and be anywhere this is
like we're in such unprecedented times
yes and you can make money from it and
this is your computer on your phone i
sit here and talk ab i can give you 100
reasons why the economy is absolutely
screwed but i can also give you a
hundred reasons as to why kids and
people without any money have it better
than anyone in in human history i mean i
remember i'm old enough uh that when i
was an entrepreneur
you would actually have to have five
hundred thousand dollars and you know to
set up a brick and mortar location or
all these things to start a business it
was a huge financial risk i mean massive
and for what you know to make a million
bucks a year or whatever where now you
can just buy some you wouldn't even have
to have something like this you go on a
shopify you just start a podcast
whatever yeah with my white couple
thousand bucks you're good to go oh not
even laptop
webcam installed yeah most of most of my
interviews i just do right off my laptop
sometimes i get fancy and have that
little mixer and everything
but the whiteboard videos that really
move the needle the most i just have a
little whiteboard a couple cameras i
mean maybe a thousand dollars worth of
equipment and if you look at
kind of the monetization strategy from
those youtube videos i'm making almost
as or maybe even more money uh with that
type of little business model than i
made having to put down you know 500 000
and a 10-year lease on a brick and
mortar location and hiring all these
employees and babysitting and all this
responsibility so and you could not have
done that back in the late 90s or the
early 2000s you can do that now and
that's a huge advantage the most
i guess
vibrant example of that is the taxi
industry used to literally have to put
down a million dollars yeah for a
medallion in new york city to be able to
have the right to drive a taxi yeah and
now you sign up you have a little car
boom you're on uber yeah you know the
gatekeeper is now gone so if you like
that clip click right here to watch
another or if you want to watch the
entire sauce cast click right here
[Music]